thank you good afternoon and welcome to
this governance and performance
governance performance and audit
committee on meeting on thursday the
26th of november 2020
my name is councillor jeanette stills
and i am the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which come into effect
on the 4th of august in response to the
kovic 19 situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through
first of all could you please could i
ask everyone present in this meeting to
ensure your microphone remains muted
and your video feed is off when not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noise and
avoid any
unintentional inter disturbances this
meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the
chat function of the meeting to indicate
you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time members are reminded
that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to
leave the meeting the chat function
should not be used
for question for for questions or
any other purposes please do not use the
raised hand function
as this is not available on all members
devices
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers
please ensure you reference a page under
or a paragraph
number and lastly if the member needs to
leave the meeting at any point
please do make this known and use the
chat function to
signify that you need to leave the
meeting
now may i ask on the off i ask officers
taking part in the meeting to introduce
themselves starting with mr dobson
good afternoon chairman good afternoon
members um paul dodson director of
strategy performance and governance
thank you mr leslie
good afternoon chris leslie director of
resources
thank you mr holmes
good afternoon chairman richard holmes
director of uh service delivery thank
you
thank you mr andrews
good afternoon chairman stephen andrews
section 106 officer
thank you mr butcher
good afternoon chairman uh stephen
butcher commercial manager
thank you mr donald miss donnelly sorry
miss donnelly
emma donnelly internal audit manager
thank you
mr geller
good afternoon chairman good afternoon
members damian geller lead specialist
community
thank you mr miss hughes sorry
good afternoon sheryl hughes programs
performance and governance manager
mr rubens good afternoon
greg rubin's bdo internal audit partner
thank you miss sanji lee motto
good afternoon uh azaria sanguly mutu
external audit
uh senior manager thank you
mr will wisdom good afternoon chair
uh craig wisdom explorer partner from
dwight
thank you mr wilson
good afternoon chair matt wilson
countryside and coast manager
thank you berna
good afternoon members bernie casey
clark to this afternoon's committee
thank you chairman thank you
are there any other officers present
that wish to make themselves known
i don't believe sir chairman thank you
berna could you now take the roll call
of members to confirm who is in
attendance
thank you chairman members i will call
your names in alphabetical order can you
please
indicate that you're in attendance
starting with councillor
chana good afternoon berna good
afternoon members and officers
um i'm present thank you council hurd
good afternoon uh chairman members and
officers i'm present
thank you councillor helm president
thank you councillor hall
president bernard
thank you councillor nunn good afternoon
berna
and chairman and members yes i'm here
thank you
thank you very much caster shaughnessy
pastor shaun lucy
i thought i saw her earlier
perhaps not um counselor stamp
is is delayed i understand chairman
councillor stills
uh yes i'm president bernard pastor
thompson
hello everyone um yes president thank
you for honor
thank you members thank you chairman
thank you
um may i have apologies for absence
please berna
yes we've received apologies for absence
from cancer keys and counselor mrs
thompson is substituting for cancer keys
this afternoon
and as i've just mentioned cancer stamp
will be joining us slightly later
thank you chairman thank you bernar um
my is it is recommended that the minutes
of the meeting held on the tweet
so i apologize sorry apologies chairman
i should ask members
in attendance to introduce themselves
now apologies for that
thank you uh have we any members in
attendance please
uh i'm in snick skins
thank you councillor skeins anybody else
thank you
yes uh i'm in attendance all but it'll
only be for about
45 minutes thank you counselor durham
lovely
and i believe cancer
and counselor morris is that correct
that's la morris in attendance
thank you very much thank you chairman
thank you
councillor morris can you turn your
video off please thank you
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 24th of
september 2020
found on pages 5 to 14 are approved as a
true
and accurate record iso move
if you wish to second that motion please
turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
stephen nunn seconded thank you
if any members wish to raise a matter of
accuracy please use the chat
function to indicate and i will invite
you to speak
i know does anybody indicated that
burner
apologies no chairman thank you these
educators
right can we take these recommendations
by consent or do we need to do a
recorded vote on the fact that
we are accepting these minutes if nobody
has any
dissent then there is no reason
for it not to be agreed by ascent happy
to agree
we approve chairman please agree thank
you
thank you all right disclosure chairman
i'm
sorry chairman i'm not saying anything
because i wasn't here i don't know i
know the
sentinel descent so i just thought i
better mention that
thank you councillor thompson
declaration of interest to disclose this
existence of any nate and any nature
any disclosable pecuniary interest
other pecuniary interest or
non-pecuniary interest relating to items
of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 628
inclusive of the code of conduct of men
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise
through the meeting i have councillor
chana
thank you chairman i wish to declare
that i'm also a member of essex county
council
it's my normal declaration it's
non-pecuniary chairman
and i wish to declare in any matter
that's pertaining to essex and most
certainly in a number of dependencies
um which are forming documents as part
of the main reports
essex county council is referred to
because obviously we've got various
partnerships
funding um issues with them and and
service delivery thank you chairman
thank you councillor chana do i have
anyone else berna
no chairman thank you thank you
item five of the agenda public
participation i can advise that we have
not received
any submissions from members of the
public
item 6 on the agenda internal reports
we move to the item six internal
audit reports uh progress of
recommendations safeguarding and cipfa
code preparedness found on pages
15-72 in a moment i will call on the
officers to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please
make this known using your chat function
within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
members the first two reports will be
presented by mr rubin's
and the second two by miss donnelly so
mr rubins can i hand over to you
yes thank you um so i'm going to speak
to page
19 of your papers which is on the
progress report
and just to pull out key items there
we have two reports we're presenting to
you today um which
uh ms donnelly will present in a moment
um
both are reasonably positive um but
obviously
um ms donnelly will take you through the
details
um we have another report on workforce
planning which is now finalized
um and will be presented to the next
meeting uh and several other audits
underway so although we're a little bit
behind
um due to covered 19 um we've got all
the work planned in for the rest of the
financial year and still expecting uh to
complete the work
um as it's under normal time frames
there's other work going on as well it
is mentioned on page 19
we've started doing work on the fraud
risk assessment uh carrying out training
for officers
and putting a training material on the
council's intranet
so i know um members were interested in
in that previous report
that we did that said you know there are
a number of gaps in the council's
arrangements particularly around
training so it's to give some assurance
that those gaps are being filled now
um it also mentions about some work
we're doing on
the new leases standard ifrs 16
to provide training and support to
officers that works been put slightly on
hold because
it's possible that standard may be
delayed by a year
um that's possibly something the
external auditors may know more about
than me but
um it is likely that that will be put
back in which case we will use those
days that time
for something else but obviously we're
waiting for a decision to be made on
that
the next paper i was going to talk to is
the follow-up
of recommendations and a short paper and
you'll see that
we're very pleased with progress uh
nearly all the recommendations that were
due for implementation have been
the only one that's outstanding relates
to the finalization of your climate
strategy which should happen
uh next month so once that has happened
we'll be able to sign that one off
so i was going to pause for questions
not for questions
can i just say on safeguarding or the
sit for code because
miss donnelly will speak to that in a
moment but if there's any questions on
the general progress or on the follow-up
of recommendations then very welcome to
take those now now counselor channel you
had your
um you indicated you wish to speak is
that to ask
mr uh rubens a question or
do you want to ask a question later uh
thank you chairman actually it will be
a bit late and it missed only i think
it's going to be
covering the area i'm probably wanting
to ask questions on thanks
thank you does any member have any
questions for mr rubin
it doesn't look like there's any
questions for you
lucky me
thank you do you want to move on to miss
donnelly to give the reports now yes
thank you chair
okay i'll start with the safeguarding
report and that's on page 35
and so the safeguarding report is a
moderate moderate assurance level report
we find that overall there were good
controls in place and we noted that the
council has
appointed a new cf guardian laid at the
start of this year
and the role of the sea of guard nate
was defined in the council's
safeguarding policy
and rules and responsibilities around
safeguarding were appropriately defined
for all the leads within the council
and for members we also found that there
were appropriate policies and procedures
in place
appropriate training is undertaken and
appropriate and pre-employment checks
including dbs
checks are being undertaken on new
joiners however
and we find that there could be some
improvements and controls
around contractors and volunteers and
working with the council
and al also around and documentation of
elements of
the safeguarding cases and we've got an
action plan for management
and um
and the council obviously are also
working to um
ensure all documentation pertaining to
safeguarding cases will be moved on to
a secure network and finally regarding
checks on
contractors and volunteers and the
council is working to compile a list
of contractors that are used regularly
and also volunteers are used regularly
and to ensure that they're appropriate
pre-employment checks
and pre-engagement checks been
undertaken and that those checks are
strengthened
and i'm not sure if there's any
questions or if this is
who i believe attended and providing
further information
thank you i've got um councillor chana
councillor thompson and councillor nunn
wishing to speak
so councillor channel uh thank you
chairman
uh yes thank you for that sort of
summary of things i have to say i was a
little
bit concerned regarding the safeguarding
report in terms of the issues that have
been picked up
and i hope i've got this right i think
it was um i hope it's a i think it was
page 38 i'm not sure if it was the
appendices or not but there was
bullet point seven and it was about
safeguarding allegations
and the stats surrounding that and it
covers offices and everything
but it made reference specifically to
say there was
no allegations against councillors but
that bullet point was silent on officers
so i thought why did it just highlight
councillors
no um allegations made against them
when it then made me to think that
perhaps being allegations against
officers so i'm interested um
in that point and i have to say i'm i'm
rather concerned about the issue of our
contractors
and volunteers not necessarily having
been dbs
checks and i heard ms donnelly say
there's a
management plan that she's aware of but
i do think bearing mind the importance
of safeguarding and being a council
obviously
the constant interaction we do have with
young people children
and vulnerable adults i was just a
little bit concerned and i'd like to
know also chairman please through you
um yes we have a new safeguarding lead
i'm not entirely clear
um that i know exactly who that new lead
is
and should we not have a member that
used to be at one time i think a member
and it came through community services i
think it was the community services
chairman
um i may be wrong on this um for
safeguarding but
perhaps members also need to have some
training on on safeguarding and being
aware of their responsibilities and the
reporting routes
because out there in the um in our local
wards and our local environment we might
see things that we need to
raise and alert so i just raised those
points chairman thank you very much
thank you i'm going to hand over to mr
holmes because i think he can answer
those points for you
thank you chairman um yes briefly a
couple of things i want to mention then
i will
um hand over to mr gayla to answer
perhaps the detail but perhaps to
reassure
councillor channel um so yes we do have
a lead officer
um and that fits very nicely with
damian's role in being the lead
um and he obviously covers our circuit
and responsibilities we also have an
internal team of officers
from right across the council which
actually work together
to ensure that our safeguarding
responsibilities are met um
i'm reassured by the the the audit we've
been through a tremendous change um
staff
and processes and obviously come through
the other side of that now and this is
really good benchmark for us to
look at the areas that we need to make
our improvements in um
so i'll ask mr gila and just to make
some comments about the specific points
uh
before you carry on so thank you thank
you right so
um my apologies council channel there
was quite a few questions there
i'll do my best to to answer them but if
there's any i've missed off please just
remind me
um so i'll start off in terms of
contractors yes you are right through
the um through the audit
um we don't have a list of approved
contractors um the the arrangement's
quite
loose but that is in the process of
being updated so that we do have a list
of approved contractors
and that we also have a robust way of
collecting their safeguarding data and
letting them know
what their requirements are and making
sure we have record of that so that's
something that's that's ongoing
uh the same also applies to volunteers
now the only difference with the
volunteer
sector is that we know the volunteer you
know we have a list of volunteers we
work with i should say
um but we want to make sure that um our
volunteers are
again you know properly registered we
know that they have checks in place
um and that we hold that in a central
location where all officers have access
to it if needed
so that's where we are in terms of
contractors
um in terms of member training
we are drawing up a program with uh
chelmsford council our partners at
chelmsford council to try and deliver
safeguarding training to members um
there are many um you know adjustments
and improvements that we need to make to
the safeguarding process at malden
and a lot of those are already underway
and they'll start to be rolled out
um over the short term
so hopefully you start to receive
invitations for training
better information in terms of
requirements and roles who's doing what
the various forms that are associated
with those
with those checks and balances as well
those are two aspects there are a couple
of other questions as well could you
please just remind me of them
um the the item really i think you
haven't answered i
mentioned the contractors and i've
referred to volunteers it was i think on
page 38 and i'm not sure if that was an
appendix series i'm putting it down
there i don't know put the appendix down
i think it might be appendix 3 actually
and i referred to bullet point 7
about safeguarding allegations and it
was saying about
you know obviously running their
paragraph and then it was saying
that the safeguarding allegations
there's obviously reports done on
officers
members etc and it said that there's no
allegations in in terms of members
so that made me to think well why isn't
there any reference to officers in that
in that paragraph because obviously if
you're saying no allegations about
members that led me to think were there
allegations about officers so really
were there any allegations that were
related to officers
reported whether internally or
externally i mean do we have an internal
mechanism which any good organization
have should have
under whistleblowing or ever or
safeguarding but that wasn't quite clear
it was just a clear statement in fact
was a sentence saying no allegations
regarding members
or received regarding members so i
thought why isn't there a statement
regarding officers within that same
bullet point
i can reassure you that there is a uh a
safeguard guarding measure and a
whistleblowing measure in relation to um
staff
and members that that is in place in
terms of the
um audit scope what the auditor took in
into account
um i can't 100 say that that
officer um reviewed any cases involving
uh officers but obviously he's noted
that he hasn't
seen anything in relation to members if
you do want me to find that specific on
it though i can
um well yes that would be helpful but as
a clear statement there but also
obviously with officers so
um you know it might be helpful if we're
making one statement about
one element of the authority it might be
useful to know the whole
make up for the authority in terms of
allegations thank you
no problems thank you
you're new to germany
sorry uh councillor thompson you had a
question
um yes thank you chairman through you
i'm not sure who i'm asking um
but i'll just ask it generally and i'm
sure you can allocate
that to an officer um counselors aren't
dbs checked and i
wondered why because although it would
be
quite unusual for me to be alone with a
vulnerable person i mean
we are often asked what in normal
circumstances not these
present times but we we can be invited
into people's homes and you know they
can be elderly and
living alone and i'm just wondering why
that doesn't apply to us
and it it was raised with me on the
doorstep once i mean then i was a
candidate
i was there as a candidate not as a
counsellor so that raises a whole other
bunch of questions but
um yeah why aren't we check because you
know we do meet people within the ward
sometimes
thank you thank you uh
mr geller do you want to answer that um
i'll have to double check on that
because some of those functions may fall
within committee services and and
those interactions how members are sort
of signed in so i will double check on
on
those sort of procedures and if it needs
updating within the
safeguarding policy i'll make sure that
happens thank you
uh i will let you come back councillor
chana but i'm going to move on
to people that haven't spoken first
councillor thompson did you want to just
come back on that
no thank you i mean i'd be grateful if
for an answer um
perhaps you know later in writing in
which case could it be circulated to all
members of the committee
as well as me as i'm only here as a sub
thank you
thank you i'm sure that uh mr geller can
do that
counselor nun i have you next uh yes
thank you very much chair and this
is a question for miss donnelly really i
think um
as a as an ex safeguarding lead for
essex schools i get
um very jumpy about safeguarding
assurance
and when i look at page 37
it says here that the effectiveness is a
moderate level
and in my mind and it might be the way
you just measure things in
audit terms but in my mind safeguarding
is either effective or it isn't
so it's either green or red
and although i can see that there are
great things in place and the future is
looking positive
uh in terms of processes and reporting
etc my first question is really to say
is this really moderate
and thank you and well i guess i would
have to defer to you i'll say the
appendix and
back of our report which outlines how we
i guess provide insurance levels and
what that means obviously
safeguarding is um a serious area and we
whenever we allocate our assurance
levels and the
the readings of our findings we do take
that into consideration so
obviously um for example there's a high
high finding
and not because we find a lot wrong but
because obviously the context of
of safeguarding obviously there's a
higher risk area
but um i guess to answer your question
we
we follow the the design of how we set
out our approach so
we obviously prevent insurance level on
the design of controls
and we provide insurance level and the
operational effectiveness
and and obviously because we have found
both good practice and areas where
controls can be strengthened
and then we've come to i guess at the
conclusion of modern crossbows but
obviously with
improvements required and obviously
because there's an
action plan in place we're content with
insurance
um thank thank through the chair thank
you miss donnelly i do
have another question chair if i'm
allowed but i believe that
mr holmes wants to respond to me as well
yeah if we can let mr holmes respond to
you and then
we'll come back
thank you chairman um yeah obviously yes
we take safeguarding very responsibly
um and obviously the example perhaps in
your background has been around schools
education young people and i
certainly understand the the importance
across any organization and i think what
we're highlighting is that
across all of the council services it
does areas have areas which are more
sensitive
um across the board the council i hope
is delivering safeguarding
responsibilities
and now picking up on the improvements
through the the audit review we can
hopefully
enhance that and make it tighter so my
feeling generally as
uh as head page services that um you
know we are providing a service but it
does need those uh areas
of specific focus and to improve it
thank you thank you uh uh councillor
stilts thank you chair and that's a very
helpful
response from miss donnelly and also
from mr holmes i'm grateful for that
uh can i ask my second question please
you can and then i've got
councillor channel that wants to come
back and council of jarvis that wants to
ask a question
so i'll let you do it thank you very
much just briefly then
uh it's a question for mr geller um
there's mentions been made of
contractors
now unless things have changed my
understanding
is that mdc would not be in a position
to undertake dbs
checks on contractors anyway are we
asking the contractors for a letter of
ease
to evidence that they have actually been
dbs
checked thank you thank you
um right so in answer to that question
uh typically um
what tends to happen is when a council
has a approved list of contractors
uh we would have an agreement of
understanding between them that they
carried out the necessary dbs checks
within their own staff
that they have adequate safeguarding
procedures should concerns be raised
through us or within their own internal
mechanisms
where we don't have a list of approved
contractors
a general sort of comment has been made
in some of the um
agreements that i've seen and the idea
is to try and
basically get that formalized that's the
whole point of the um the approved
contractors list that we know these
people we trust them we've seen their
procedures and we're happy with it
and the idea to hold it corporately is
obviously so that you know
everyone that needs to have access to
that data can have access to that data
uh thank you chair um thank you mr
geller that's very helpful
are they my questions thank you thank
you um
councillor chan you wanted to come back
to clarify something
um thank you jen it wasn't to clarify it
was to inform really just to say
and i did declare an interest i'm also
an essex county councillor
i have been dbs checked essex does do
that
i think i have the highest level if i
recall right level three i think or
whatever it is
and obviously because awareness of
members actually
having contact with elderly vulnerable
people
young people and children obviously um
are going to
have done in the past gone into
children's homes and elsewhere
and into uh care homes for elderly so
that is a good point about council as
being
dbs because um you know i think that
gives act
actually extra security and uh if you
like confidence
and knowledge to the authority in terms
of
counsellors it also protects counsellors
because i can say now
if whenever i go into a place or need to
um if it's required of me to say that i
have been
dbs checked and i do have the documents
to actually underpin that and show that
if required
thank you counselor chana councillor
jarvis you wanted to ask a question
yes thank you chairman um i think my
question is
um probably to uh miss donnelly
and then also perhaps also a comment um
from mr holmes
it's really just a question of time
scale i noticed that this this
is a report which is flagged up as reds
you know some sort of uh
issues that are more serious uh and yet
i
i think i've read through it i think
it's talking about a
sort of completion date of reactivation
of sort of the end of next year
i was just trying to get my head around
why something that would be flagged up
that was red and urgent
uh we'd be happy about a sort of
implementation date
of the year um so i i wanted to ask
that question to ms donnelly first is
that
usual for something red to be a year and
then perhaps ask richard holmes to
comment in more detail
thank you and i guess obviously we would
like to see
a realistic d itself say that the first
thing and
obviously we don't want something that
the council prompts us to deliver and
then
obviously it's pushed back and where and
here's where the
um implementation needs are quite far
away
and considering obviously that is um
there is a high finding in there
what i would like to do is probably do
maybe a progress update
um after a period of time to see you
know or are
still on track for those dates obviously
there is um
an element of a system refresher a new
system involved so i
assume that's probably why they've gone
for a longer and date and time
but i'm sure um richard you may be able
to provide a bit more information
but again in that scenario we would like
to get a progress update
after a period of time just to see if
everything's progressing as it should be
thank you thank you thank you thank you
uh
mrs donnelly i missed donald thank you
uh councillor jarvis
uh council uh mr geller you actually
want to come back
on that yes through sorry chairman
through you i
think i did ask the chairman if it's
okay for mr holmes to comment as well i
think he was just going to join sorry
all right sorry oliver
do you want to get mr geller to come
back and then mr holmes
um whichever way
all i say perhaps initially then is that
i do agree that we should break down
that time scale because i think the
other
aspects of it that we need to do more
sooner and quickly um i think this delay
will give you a little bit of detail on
that now
thank you richard thank you thank you um
yes council jarvis just just to try and
uh answer that question uh the intention
is to um to basically implement the
system
as soon as possible and the reason for
the the uh
longer leading date is to make sure the
system's bedded in properly
to within that process make sure that we
can check that the
the different things that we're putting
in place are going to work
in terms of the system implementation
that should be quite quick uh it's
literally just a case of
we're waiting for licenses um to be
approved and then we can basically get
users
set up uh in that regard uh we can then
start to
build the system out in terms of what we
need it to do so we already have the
system we just need the licenses to
bring in extra users
and then we just need to adapt the
system slightly so that it can take what
we need it to do
but obviously because of the nature of
safeguarding we want to make sure it's
fit for purpose we want to give it a
little while to embed
and then review what we've got so that's
the reason for the lead-in date and as
ms donnelly has mentioned it is
absolutely about making sure that the
process is working properly
thank chairman just through you thank
you davey and thank you mr hampton i
think as mr holmes has said chairman i
think in this particular case what we
really would
should have coming back to committee is
the more detailed break breakdown of a
timetable
so that we can see that the key
vulnerable points are actually being
addressed much earlier than the year end
thank you jen
thank you council judge i actually have
a question for you mr geller
um are we subscribing to the essex
county council app
tribe no no that's not a system we're
using unfortunately now
the systems we have system in place at
the minute called fresh serve that's
used to deal with a number of different
functions across the council
um in relation to the
processes that in safeguarding triggers
um fresh serve should be able to
accommodate those those trigger points
um it's a system that's already up and
running and embedded within malden so
the idea that we can
basically just get it to do what we need
to do for safeguarding should be quite a
quick win but no we don't use
we don't use tribe um also i do know
um that for example uh the community
safety department in chelmsford they
actually use microsoft dynamics
um and if we were to implement a system
that was a system that would probably be
the closest one
because we already have links in with
the community safety team there
thank you and can you assure me that
fresh serve will be secure enough for
this information
yes yes i can assure you that thank you
is there any other questions for miss
donnelly mr holmes or mr geller
there's no indication in the chat feed
chairman
thank you uh miss donnelly have you got
anything
else you want to go on to um i'll move
on to the
um financial management code report on
page 55.
um okay so this is a substantial
substantial report
looking at the council's compliance with
the new financial management code before
the first year of required compliance
which begins at next year 21-22
and we found a role the council was
prepared for the new code however
and we just noted one finding where they
can strengthen links between the
individual and
service strategies and then the
council's overall corporate plan and the
themes within the corporate plan
and but obviously we note in the
management response that this is already
in progress as a plan and the strategies
are up for review currently
thank you is there any questions on this
for miss donnelly
no no
thank you um if there's no more
questions and
do you have anything else to add miss
donnelly
well mr rubens
nothing for me no thank you okay thank
you
if there's nothing else then we'll move
on to the recommendations
in the repo so the recommendations are
as
follows that the committee considers
comments and approves
the internal audit progress report
november 2020 at apex one
and follow up the recommendation report
november 2020
at apex 2 and 3
safeguarding audit november 2020
apex 3 and 4
the cipfa code preparedness
at november 2020 apex
4. if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video unmute
your microphone and state your name now
counselor none uh seconded
thank you
do i have anyone else to speak no um
can we take these recommendations
um by consent or do you need to have a
recorded vote on them
happy we consent chairman
thank you thank you thank you
agree agreed burner uh
sorry thank you chairman thank you
agenda item 7
external audit report we move to agenda
item 7 the external audit report found
on pages 73-78
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on the item please make this known
by using the chat function within this
meeting
and i will come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
mr wisdom please present the report
thank you chairman um the the reporters
included in the pack was the one that
was presented
to the previous uh meeting and it's
there for information i i don't intend
to go through the whole report again
chairman what i i do want to say though
is that
um following that report we have now
satisfactorily
uh concluded uh the work that was that
was listed as outstanding
in that report and there are no
additional items that i
would like to bring to the attention of
the committee in respect of
the completion of that work i can
confirm that
following completion of the work and as
outlined in our
september report we will be issuing a
clean opinion
uh with an emphasis of matter in
relation to the
material uncertainty around asset
valuation
so just a reminder that that is an
unmodified
and an unqualified opinion so as i say a
clean opinion
we are also issuing a clean conclusion
on the value for money
arrangements that are in place in place
and i suppose the final thing i would
like to say chair is that
we will present a summary of all the
work as we're required to do in the
summary annual order letter
which will come to the next world
committee but we are ready to sign
the accounts i'm following your approval
today
thank you councillor chana you have a
question
uh thank you very much chairman um yes
really um
it's mostly relating to appendix one but
it is the issue of the significant risk
and i
i know mr wisdom has just made reference
to that about the valuations however
it has been highlighted in the report
i've read a significant risk because for
two years running in a row
the valuations there's been material
errors that's what i've read
and then on page 16 of appendix one
um it does again highlight that and
we've got the red dot and we've got the
various um
orange dots and very things but it does
say within the text that management of
raspberry
revisit the engagement letter i'm just
wondering could you expand a little bit
please and um
bearing in mind the misstatement appears
to what i can see
have um 1.4 million um came into the
equation
at one point um i'd just be grateful for
a bit of expansion on that please
because i think this is quite um well
obviously it's been highlighted as a
significant risk so it is very very
important
uh thank you um so i'll um
i'll possibly uh councillor leslie will
will
that's not counselor officer little even
um we'll have
i've elevated in there we'll uh we'll uh
comment as well but from from an order
perspective
uh you're absolutely right at council
channel that that we did identified as a
significant risk we did identify that
there were there were errors made by the
valuer
and as a result of that we had to do
additional work
um i do know that the um that the
officers have
been back to the valuers to to pick
pick that up with them and perhaps uh
officer leslie can
and can comment on that further on where
they've got to
but from my perspective i've made some
recommendations to officers and they
have accepted
those recommendations and appear to be
moving forward
on those recommendations and i will pick
up the
follow-up um on our through the course
of our next order
thank you mr wisdom uh
mr leslie do you want to come back on
that
yeah i have to pick up on that now uh
chairman's been also going to mention it
uh in the next item
but i have to pick up on it now so yes
we've come across obviously some
recommendations that your external
audit has made fully uh support and
embrace those recommendations uh
they're quite right and we put in place
a plan after discussions with the
external auditors
and internal uh and sorry external
valuers
um to look at how we can improve the
process going
forward and part of that is bringing
forward the timetable
for the valuations to ensure there's
some uh there is sufficient
time for uh checking to take place
and we have engaged with the valuers uh
a meeting and set out a timetable and
expectations we've already provided
the valuers with the information for the
valuations
this year they already have that and
they are already carrying out
the valuations for this year so we've
already put that
in place and we've moved forward that
timetable so we have much more time
for checking quality assurance and
making sure that all the information
is there and then we're talking with the
valuers so that's very much uh underway
for this year thank you mr leslie uh
councillor chan are you quite happy with
that
uh yes i am chairman thank you very much
i thank
mr wisdom and mr leslie for that
expansion of um
you know the detail i saw thank you
thank you
is there any other questions for mr
leslie or mr wisdom
no not at the moment chairman thank you
um so the recommendation then is set out
as
in the report as follows so the
recommendation
is that the report of the external
auditor apex one is
noted any member wishing to second that
please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
hello chairman me again uh councillor
nine i'll second that thank you
thank you um is everybody happy to
accept that on consent
[Music]
lovely thank you agreed great
item a statement of accounts
we move to the agenda item eight
statement of council members please note
that the original
agenda documents have been replaced and
the papers in the supplementary pack
circulated today should be found
on pages 3 to 104 of that pack
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please make you
known by using the chat function within
this meeting then i will come to you in
turn
please keep your points clear and
succinct mr
leslie would you like to present your
report
yes thank you um as always
already has been mentioned a
supplementary uh item
has been issued uh for this uh in
relation to
what uh mr wisdom has already spoken
about
and that we now are in a position to uh
approve
the accounts uh just to run through
the key changes since the original
agenda pack was issued
to members obviously the recommendation
has now changed to
approve the statement of accounts in
light of what mr wisdom has already
uh mentioned in relation to the actual
statement
of accounts itself what's changed
from that is that a variety of
formatting changes um
have been addressed now we can see some
highlights obviously come
quite clear you know in a color copy so
some minor amendments around that
we've also added a breakdown of
valuations by year
in table uh in the table
in november 10 that's actually on page
49
of the statement of accounts so that's a
bit more in detail
around that there's been some changes to
lines on the cash flow statement
on page 20 the statement of accounts and
the associated notes
on page 64. uh however the overall cash
amount
remains unchanged so there's a movement
between those lines
and finally the inclusion of the authors
report as well on page 75.
and apart from these minor changes the
accounts remain substantially unchanged
those which you have previously been
issued
just to talk uh through some of the
highlights in the statement of accounts
obviously the final position for 2019-20
was reported to council on the
6th of august in the financial app turn
report
which provided detailed information
about the outter
following completion of the audit those
figures remain unchanged uh there was a
reported increase in the general fund
balance of 700
000 and 1.5 million increase in the
earmarked reserves
back in august and you can see that in
the accounts that's page 16 of the
statement of accounts there's the
movement
in reserves statement and within that
you can see
the increase in in those reserves
uh you can also see that at the end of
the year the general fund balance stood
at
5.5 million and earmarked reserves
stood at 1.4 million as previously
reported
back in august it's worth noting as well
that the capital receipts reserve
is shown there and that shows at 2.3
million and this can only be used to
fund
capital expenditure
transfers to and from reserves are shown
on page
25 of the statement of accounts
and so it shows the individual earmarked
reserves um
where there are transfers to and from
and a bit further on on
the following page on page 46 there is
also an explanation
of what those earmarked reserves relate
to
just picking up some highlights from the
balance sheet
on page 19. the council has about 31
million of
land and buildings the largest assets
being the offices and the two leisure
centres
it also has three million of what's
classed as investment property
and that's mainly the springfield
industrial site
also uh highlight that the council held
12 million
in cash equivalents given a high level
of
liquidity uh at the end of the year
there
now just uh to move on to other parts i
mean on page 37
for example and elsewhere in the
accounts it does give a mention to
kovig 19 mr mr wisdom has already picked
up
on the implications around the
valuations
and indeed the statement of accounts
does highlight the uncertainties around
this
particularly in relation to those asset
valuations
regular updates on the current financial
position are of course provided to the
snr uh committee which are publicly
available
now the deadline for the accounts to be
signed off this year is the 30th
of november as previously reported to
the committee
further information required in relation
to the pension fund and valuations
prevented the accounts from being signed
off even earlier this year
of course the pension fund is
administrated by essex county council
and further information was needed from
the actuaries the council
uh was also required to carry out
additional valuations on its property by
um by its external valuer
and that of course does take time
to do so from my perspective
the audit showed there were good
foundations in terms of
key financial controls however it did
highlight aspects of improvement
in a couple of contained areas for one
the template for the statement of
accounts it presents poorly and i think
perhaps you can see that it does present
uh poorly and it's actually quite
difficult to format from offering an
operational
point of view that may seem a very minor
point
but actually in terms of the risk around
uh typos or
administrative type errors i think that
is actually quite um
quite a impact for us um and the other
of course is the valuations
which were being spoken about but we
have engaged the valuers
early uh and as a result of that we're
making sure that
there's enough time to increase the
quality checking
around that aspect in response a new
statement of accounts template is
currently
being developed that's been looked at
right now someone is building that
uh and the values as we said have also
been engaged
early around this area uh thank you
thank you councillor nan you have a
question
um well actually chair i'm not sure if
this is appropriate it's not really a
question it's just a statement really
i'd just like to uh
thank mr leslie and his team for the
preparation of these accounts
given the journey this authority's been
on in the short time that i've been a
district councillor
and the preparation of accounts uh and
uh the way that these have been
presented
and the assurance that we've had of the
audit check i just think it's a great
achievement and i just
like to go on record uh to say thank you
to mr leslie and his team
thank you councillor nan i'm sure mr
leslie is very appreciative of that
um are there any other questions for mr
leslie
no chairman thank you burner um
so there therefore we oh oh sorry
chairman
would like to speak i think yeah thank
you
thank you chairman just to apologize for
attending late but i'd also like to echo
what council nuns just said
uh there's a lot of hard work going on
to this and i think mr leslie and his
team
need to be commended uh thank you and i
do apologize for being late but i did
let you know the reason
for it thank you chair thank you
councillor stamp
um so therefore we remove we've moved to
the recommendations
uh which are set out in the report as
follows
the recommendations one that the
statement of accounts for 2019-20
including the annual government
statement at appendix one
be approved and two
that the letter of representation at
appendix 2
be approved if any member wishes to
second that motion please turn on your
video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
german councillor jarvis i'm very happy
to second that motion
thank you councillor jarvis um our
members happy to accept that on consent
agreements thank you
agenda item nine quarter
two review of corporate performance
we move to agenda item 9 the quarter 2
review
of corporate performance found on pages
193 to 218.
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
members are reminded that if you wish to
speak on this item please make sure that
this
is known by using the chat function
within this meeting i will come to you
in turn please keep your question
your points clear and succinct mr holmes
would you like to
present the report
chairman i believe does miss hughes oh
sorry miss hughes sorry
yep no problem um good afternoon members
so the performance report for
quarter two which covers july to
september
um is provided for committee review to
track the delivery of the corporate plan
as highlighted in previous reporting
there are measures which are not
performing according to where we thought
we would be
and this is largely down to the impact
of covid and where we've had to deliver
services differently or where officer
resources have been diverted you will
see in section
3.3 of the covering report a summary
table that highlights for each of the
three themes
the number of measures that are either
on track or otherwise
this follows feedback from previous
committee meetings to give a high level
view
section 3.4 then highlights the specific
measures for concern
which this month this quarter are
for community um molden district council
assistance to use digital services at
the council offices
for place local volunteering activity
facilitated by
mdc uh keeping britain tidy green flag
award for parks and open spaces and
develop and adopt
the environmental and climate change
strategy
and for prosperity the percentage of
strategic sites promoted through
partners
and the occupancy in the enterprise hub
the appendix found on pages 197-217
is the full set of data and supporting
plans that help us draw those
conclusions
and monitor and track delivery some of
the new activity that has taken place
but was not originally on the
corporate plan has included virtual
fitness campaigns
as opposed to events at the leisure
center grow your own vegetables
direct engagement with those in
isolation risk groups for covid which
far surpasses the original target number
of people that we hope to reach in
social isolation
an increase in channel shift as a result
of the closure of the offices which has
helped
people to use online tools
volunteering activity for open spaces
has been redeployed to the covid
response
and conversation with 80 businesses in
the high street as part of the covet
response
this helps to illustrate that although
we said we would deliver some of the
objectives this has changed
but there is additional activity in some
places that underpins the wider
corporate goals
there's a wider review of the corporate
plan objectives being
undertaken by the strategy team at
present and we're feeding into this to
ensure
appropriate performance reporting will
be produced as part of this
also in the january meeting we intend to
bring an additional report with the
exceptions to
operational level performance reporting
which
is called the balance scorecard for
members thank you
thank you do i have anybody
wishing to ask miss hughes any questions
not at the moment sharon thank you
um
we have recommendations within the
report
the recommendations are that the members
review the information as set out in
this report
and appendix one with priority focus
being given to strategic
outcomes level performance item
uh item two that the members confirm
they are still
assumed us assured
that through this review that corporate
performance is being managed effectively
any member wishing to second those
motions please turn on your video
and mute your microphone and state your
name now
council heard i'm happy to second that
thank you our members happy to take that
by consent great
thank you agreed
item 10 on your um
agenda is the corporate risk
we move to item 10 which is the
quarterly
review of corporate risk found on pages
219-226
in a moment i'll call on the officer to
present this item
members are reminded that if you wish to
speak on the item please make this known
by using the chat function within this
meeting
i will then come to you please keep your
questions clear and succinct miss hughes
would you like to
present this report
yes thank you and so good afternoon
members again
um the report deals with quarter two
risk
reporting so this is covering july to
september 2020
and in summary for changes since quarter
one
um which is shown in 3.2.1 of the
covering report
just to take you through so there's one
risk that's seen a decrease in score
which is r26 failure to deliver channel
shift
and because as a result of current
online operations and customer shift
as part of the cobid response we're
currently seeing around 90
of all our contact online
and there's one risk that's seen an
increase in score this is
r25 which was failure to deliver
transformation program finance finances
um this is because commercial income
targets are like
unlikely to be met as due to the
impact of the pandemic there are three
risks that have been recommended for
closure which are r12
r24 and r26 r12 is around a committee
structure which is not cost effective
um the cost the structure for committees
has been in place since
october 2009 and the corporate
governance working
group have reviewed any recommended
changes and those have now been
considered by council
so that's why this one's recommended for
closure
r24 is around loss of key skills and
knowledge and a
failure to embrace new ways of working
um
staff have now been working in an agile
and digital way and
managing service delivery remotely even
since march 2020
r26 is around failure to deliver channel
shift
and as i mentioned before the
significant majority of contact is being
driven online
in person and phone contact is still
available for those who need it most but
we're seeing
high volumes of contact um online
clt continue to regularly monitor and
review the risks
given the emergency pandemic measures
and at an operational
level we now have the additional level
of the balance scorecard that i
mentioned before
which helps us to monitor risks even
once they're removed from this corporate
register
which means that should the controls
stop working we can then escalate them
back up so as an example the channel
shift figures
although are recommended for closure
will be continued to monitor
those in the balanced scorecard and
should channel shift
change we can obviously report that back
up again
thank you thank you misuse uh counselor
channel you have
a question uh thank you chairman yes i
do
uh just make sure i get it right it's
about uh risk r23
which is in the appendix and it's page
two two three or page three whichever
way you look at it
um and that's relating to um
obviously uh process uh financial
issues and it mentions about um
a shortage in the team of one person but
it does state that
once that's been recruited to i read it
to understand the risk may be reduced
just like to understand where we are in
that process then regarding
uh getting that vacancy a field that
appears to
result in this slide slightly higher
rating
for that risk thank you um
miss huge do you want to come back or do
you want to hand that to mr holmes
uh that's actually probably one that
might be better for um
chris leslie mr leslie
yeah yep thank you yeah that's certainly
something
uh we're looking into um
at the moment and taking measures to uh
to address that um
happy to pick up on any uh sort of other
specific points around that
well yes can i come back chairman yes
you might
looking to address it can you just
advise then where we are with
the measures we're doing to address it
thanks and what they are
yeah sorry i do apologize um i've had a
trouble with the connection uh in terms
of that so i didn't catch all the
discussion
uh but sorry perhaps penny uh council
channel would you mind just well it was
our it was our 23
which is we got reference to uh
financial resources
and process and it referred to the fact
that about stability which is obviously
very important
and it appears to be we have a vacant
position and it was stating that once
perhaps we recruit to that
this is my words perhaps now um that
then that would mean the risk could be
reduced
and obviously the stability would
improve so really i was seeking to know
um when we think that process might be
done so that we do see a reduction in
that risk rating because obviously it's
elevated due to that vacant position
position is it exactly thanks frank yeah
now that that's helpful thank you
apologies for those i didn't catch it
right so in terms of the action we've
taken to address that obviously we've
been out to
to recruit to to that role um
and we have been uh successful in doing
so so now that vacancy
um subject to obviously references etc
will
um be filled which will reduce
a major sort of reliance on temporary
staff
around that side so
hopefully very shortly we'll be able to
clear that off as actually that resource
issue is no longer uh a problem
and actually we do have the resources uh
in place but of course we have to
monitor that as we go forward
in terms of fresh demands etc that are
placed on via covered or
just normal business as usual so that
that's the current action as they're in
place
uh i believe we'll have that filled
fingers crossed
instead of uh a month or so time
chairman might just come back on
something yes
if it says once that's um uh positions
got someone in it then what rating um
sort of reduction-wise do you think that
might go down by
on the risk score um
yeah yeah that's right through yourself
uh i think we're not we'll have to take
a view
uh once the resources are embedded um
and come back i think
potentially we could look to to remove
that altogether
uh wouldn't necessarily be any higher
than the risk of any other service
uh resources so there's a chance that
actually we could remove it all together
but i think we would need to
like make this a cancellation i'd
probably have to take a view um
later on once it's all embedded and we
know where we are
thank you thank you thank you mr leslie
so apologies to sorry
thank you uh mr councillor heard you
have a question
um thank you chairman well again not a
question but a statement uh i really am
reassured
uh on this and uh bearing in mind that
uh
this is our job to review this risk
policy
uh and i'm very pleased to see that from
quarter one to quarter two
uh that there is only one that has been
raised and that's not our fault that's
the
uh the effect of covid
um but indeed we're closing um three of
those risks
and one of those uh was one that we've
seen the decrease in
in our 26. so overall
again thank you to the officers for
their for their good work
and this is uh progression because we're
leaving this report with fewer risks
than we had
so well done to all thank you uh
councillor hurd are there any other
questions bernar
no chairman thank you so we moved to
recommendations the recommendations are
set up with
in the report as follows recommendation
one that members
note the change in scoring in this
report to reflect
recent policy updates uh recommendation
was that the members review the
corporate risk register in appendix 1
and approved the comment and feedback
for consideration
three that the members are assured
through this review that the corporate
risk is being managed effectively
and four that the members challenge risk
where the committee feels that the
council's corporate goals may not be
achieved
if any member wishes to second that
mission please turn on your video and
mute your microphone and state your name
now castle hill my second there
thank you councillor hill our members
happy to take that by consent
agrees agreed great agreed
thank you we move on to agenda item
11 section 106 update report
and the first malden district council's
infrastructure funding statement
this is found in pages
227 to 234
in a moment i will call the officer to
present the item members are
a reminder that you may may you wish to
speak on this
item please make this known by using the
chat function within the meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
mr dobson would you like to present your
report
yes thank you chairman um
that this report provides members an
update on
some of the progress with section 106
service delivery
and as indicated at the the june meeting
of of this committee
it also brings forward a draft
infrastructure funding statement
the infrastructure funding statement is
a new requirement of government and this
will be the first year
that we've submitted uh
the statement that's not due until
um the 31st of december so
hence it's a draft statement that that's
included in the appendix of this report
so one of the the requests within the
report is that as that's finalized
that the um sign off of that is
delegated to myself as the the director
in consultation with the chairman
um of the the committee um
in terms of the the funding statement
and and some of the the key progress
that's been made um a lot of work has
been done
throughout the year in gathering the
information in updating and reconciling
um the section 106 information too
um i'm very aware that members are keen
to see
um you know the detail behind the
the section 106 funding and what we're
looking to do
is to to not only update that um for
members
as part of this process but also to to
put that information
on our website so something of a a step
change
that's planned for the new year in the
way that we report the section 106
information
it's also proposed that to as we go
through that process
we're going to hold a workshop for
members
to take them through all of that detail
early in the new year and i think we're
putting that in place for the
the second week in january when um all
of the
you know when everybody's back after
christmas so that we can go through that
so the the the statement is provided
as a draft in um appendix one
um i would just draw what was we've not
got that much data
in at the moment i'm afraid i have to
draw your attention to um
the affordable housing
um figures which actually are an
underestimate it says 150
on page three two and it should be um
one five six so so an improvement on
that
um but both myself and the um
section 106 officer um stephen andrews
are in attendance if there are any
questions from members
thank you thank you i have a question
from councillor chana
uh thank you madam chairman now i hate
to be a party pooper here
but i'm afraid i might be seen as that
i do have some concerns about
recommendation little too
um and nothing of course against you
chairman or
mr dobson
but bear in mind this is a very very
important document in my book because
actually
this document will actually maintain
the council's commitment to the idp the
infrastructure delivery plan
and as we know that is a document which
is actually was tested on examination
alongside the ldp back in 2017.
so i this i see this much this document
very much
related to if not in itself a policy
document
i know it gives the details on
performance um but i do have some
some concerns i think it's something all
members do need to see at the
appropriate stage to question it
um because as i say i hope i've
highlighted sufficiently there
the importance as to why and um
i'm glad to hear there's going to be a
workshop as well but they're my main
points in this and also
i i recognize this might be seen as
performance showing how the 106 is
have applied or whatever i've read the
statement but isn't this something also
that strategy and resources needed to be
aware of bearing in mind fundamentally
that they will be looking at no doubt
the ldp and issues surrounding that such
as the idp
and so this is a suite of documents in a
way that actually are intrinsically
linked with synergies um and policy
matters
so that's just my concern sherman it's
nothing
uh to say that you're not perfectly
capable both of you to sign it off but i
just wondering really
if it should come back to committee to
see the actual finite detail
thank you councillor channel mr dobson
would you like to answer that
yes thank you chairman um
we're more than happy to to bring back a
copy of the
um the the statement
once completed um and for members to to
be able to scrutinize it
in detail um it will be a matter of
fact the the the figures that go into it
is um you know it's a statement so it is
based on
the the money in the money out and
yes we'll be doing further reviews which
we're looking at the infrastructure um
delivery plan currently at the moment as
well
um we'll take
that detail as we go through the um
any policy changes related to
to the infrastructure delivery we'll
take that through strategy and resources
and obviously this statement is a
supporting document
to to any of that information but this
response itself is a fairly high level
um statement of of what has happened
this year so whilst we could bring that
back
to committee following its its
submission
so that you know it's transparent it's
published and all members
see that it will be that a statement of
what has happened this year
are you happy with that counselor
channel
uh yeah i suppose so
basically yeah i still have concerns
bearing in mind it's a very important
under
well underpinning document as unlinked
as i said earlier intrinsically
with synergies to do with the idp and
indeed the ldp
um it's fundamental mr andrews you're
lit up you want to speak
yes through you chairman and paul i i
think it's
a point well taken and one which we can
accommodate i think i've
alluded to in that i think has got to be
the proper linkages
in the web page document to the existing
infrastructure delivery program so we
can
so we can firm up that relationship but
because the infrastructure delivery
program review has been going through
we haven't had an opportunity yet to
broach
the future plans for infrastructure
delivery and we can really only rest on
the one that we've got
as you quite rightly point out council
channel was actually taken through
inquiry process thank you mr andrews
can i come to councillor stamp you have
a question
um yes i do i actually agree with
councillor chana
we've all been waiting for still and for
all this
infrastructure delivery statements to
come forward
can i make a suggestion please chairman
that little two is amended and we also
include the leader of the council
and the leaders of the other groups i
don't think an
additional two or three of the people at
this meeting to agree
the statement can hurt and and i totally
take on board
what council chan has said i think it
needs to be done inclusively and i hope
that
mr dodson that's okay uh with you uh
and you chairman thank you mr dodson are
you happy to
accept that amendment to littleton
of course chairman always happy to to
consult with members and to get um
further advice on that would be um
helpful thank you
okay uh berna do you need the actual
wording for that
uh amendment change uh chairman i i
think i've i've got it
that council stamp would like to also
include the leader of the council and
the leader of the other
relevant groups but obviously i'll name
the actual groups
when i amend the recommendation thank
you
i need a second to chairman though i
haven't been secretary i i was just
about to come to that case
i'm gonna say i'll second it obviously
because i faced the matter
but thank you to councillor stamp for
making the proposal
thank you um so it has been seconded
are you happy to take those two
recommendations with that amendment
on consent so that is that the members
note the content of this report and full
the format and layout of the draft
instruct
infrastructure statement and then little
to
with the addition that that will be the
leaders of both party of
all parties um for
that recommendation and the leader of
the council and the leader of the
council
yeah if any member wishes to second that
motion
we've done that sorry um would members
like to take
that on consent now all right great
agreed agreed
thank you thank you mr dobson
um item
12 is a health and safety update for
quarter two
we moved to agenda item 12 the health
and safety update for quarter two found
on pages two three five two two three
eight in a moment i will call on the
officer to present this item
members are reminded if you wish to
speak on the item please make this known
by using the chat function within this
meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
mr holmes would you like to present your
report
thank you chairman yes so well um so
this is the health and safety update
report for quarter two for the period
uh running from july to september the
recommendations are to note the accident
incident uh statistics and also the
health and safety update
so firstly to pick up on the incident
statistics
there were three accidents during this
quarter two
involved staff within the parks team
which were minor in nature a cut and
handling waste and a sprain
and they're also an injury to a young
child who fell down a hole which opened
beside the
marine lake at promenade park um the
charges to sign
unfortunately a fracture and therefore
reported that to the health and safety
executives were required to do
uh immediate measures were taken to
prevent further risk and i understand
that the work has now been completed uh
to a standard which should stop that
happening again as it was connected to
erosion between the water and
the earth bank beside um we also had
four incidents of unacceptable behaviour
during the period
one of them in the housing one in waste
and two reported by other agencies
um although this is a report that looks
into uh quarter two there's been quite a
lot of activity uh
recently just after the period and i
think it's probably worth mentioning now
some of those activities
rather than wait for the next update
when we'll obviously formalize that
in the next upgrade report but we have
been working with the health and safety
executive of a hand-on vibration
and there's a visit been made to review
our procedures a number of
activities have undertaken to work with
our team to improve the situation
uh over recording of use of equipment
and we're also working on risk
assessments and training
i do have mr wilson on the line who
manages the uh the team
so with your permission i'd like mr
wilson just to give you a brief update
of the current activities please
thank you mr wilson thank you chair
um yes so over the next quarter we've
got a number of
activities taking place particularly
around training for staff
what we get what we've had in place
up-to-date has been adequate
particularly in our correspondence with
the hsc over the last couple of years
around
their concerns with haves across the
industry and local authority
uh we're making some improvements as
well so all staff have undertaken
an ios accredited working safety course
um so that's part
park staff cemetery staff maintenance
team that was on the 8th
and 15th of october we have
hand on vibration awareness training uh
in terms of
uh indicators for physical self and and
also
how to work safely and more
appropriately with vibrating machinery
that's being undertaken at the beginning
of december again for all staff in
our park sems maintenance and facilities
team as well
we are upgrading our
hand on vibration assessment it's
usually
once every two years that was a
recommendation from our
occupational health provider uh so all
staff undertook that in august
2019 following sunday's discussion with
the hsc inspired so we're gonna make
that annual
um so there's now an online assessment
tool that staff are undertaking um
we also have an external contract coming
in to do some on-site assessments of the
machinery that we do use that's in
current operation
to make sure that all the tolerance
levels are correct so trigger times are
appropriate for staff to be using them
in the new year we have some risk
assessment and method statement training
again an external contract is coming in
with two two-day courses for staff
our risk assessments are adequate um
they could be better they are
the intention behind the the training
will be they'll be very front line led
so actually the staff on the ground who
are doing the work tend to input more
into what the risk assessments actually
say to make it safer for them on the
front line
this will include normal operating
procedures
and method statements for complex works
out on site
and we'll that will update everything
for again parks and maintenance
primarily
um in terms of cemeteries
as members will be aware we've taken uh
cemeteries
um grave digging particularly back in
house recently
and there's been a number of concerns
raised around the processes that have
been used historically
and sem service so we've
already commissioned a suite of normal
operating procedures which we'll update
all of our risk assessments upon
we've got some great best practice
guidance from real industry leaders and
people who
write the courses for other local
authorities um
and we're moving on with our memorial
safety testing as well
so we've just had training at the
beginning of this week for staff
involved in that process
thank you councillor hull you have a
question
i take it counselor how you you have
asked to speak
i've just got in sorry i was on the
phone
i was on the i couldn't get in um
the first day training do all the
counsellors do that
sort of course do you know
can you hear me yeah i can hear you
are you asking if the counselors do the
calls are the council employees
the employers not not all employees do
so there
are designated first aiders within the
office space in normal times
um who are nominated to respond all of
the
park staff to the operational staff who
are out on the ground they all undertake
first aid training just because the
nature of the work and machinery they
use
it's quite handy to do it i know we've
been doing it with all our
crew and it's been worked really well
thank you
thank you and our staff are also
um especially the parks team they are um
trained in the use of the defibrillator
and on
anaphylaxis aren't they they're
certainly in the defibrillator and
anaphylaxis has covered
um use of effie pens and those sorts of
things in the courses we commissioned
because
they are relatively common in public
spaces thank you
are there any other questions
nobody's indicated chairman thank you so
therefore we have two recommendations
the recommendation one is to note the
accident
incident statistics and recommendation
two is to note the health
and safety activity for quarter two
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
and state your name now
counselor none uh seconded chairman
thank you are you happy to take that
motion by consent
noted
so item 13 appointment of
representatives on liaison committee
panels we move to item
30 on pages 239 to 240
in a minute i will ask the officer to
present this report but can i remind
members to if you wish to speak to use
the chat button
and i will come to you please keep your
answers
clear and sustain counselor nun you have
a question can i let the officer do his
report first
yes of course chair thank you so mr
dobson would you like to present your
report
yes thank you chairman um this report
follows the
statutory meeting of council at which um
the committees were reappointed
and following on from that there's now
uh a need for
members to be appointed to outside
bodies
and liaison committees the
this report outlines the current the the
bodies to be appointed to the current
representatives
and the um vacancies that are open to
nomination
i would just like to point out that the
places for people liaison committee
uh which is listed here um is listed in
error that was actually
appointed to by strategy and resources
committee
and those positions have have been
filled so i apologize for that that
shouldn't have been on the list
thank you chairman thank you there is a
recommendation that the committee
appoints representatives to the body
detailed in the report for the remainder
of the municipal year to may 20
21 if any member would like to second
that motion please turn on your video
and unmute your microphone
secondary show thank you councillor now
councillor nan will you stay there
because you did want to speak
well um yes thank you chair only in so
much as
the first item which is morton cab
um i note that councillor bamford
was a representative obviously she's no
longer a
a member of this council and i would
like to propose that councillor
flo shaughnessy replaces councillor
bamford and joins
uh councillor chana and councillor
jarvis thank you very much chair
seconded thank you councillor channel
you wish to speak
yes uh uh thank you chairman um actually
chairman
um can i propose really that instead of
myself on the citizens advice bureau
um that actually uh that place will be
taken by
councillor keys councillor keys is not
here to say whether he agrees to that
but
he does indeed i can tell you he does
thank you
through the chair i'm happy to give way
on that uh
and uh would be supportive of councillor
keys as well as
councillor jarvis and councillor shawnee
thank you
thank you if there's no nothing else
then we'll move on to the second one
which is the malden district
museum liaison committee um
there was councillor bamford and
councillor durham on that
but councillor durham is no longer on
this committee and councillor bedford
has left so i need two members for this
group
council channel um oh thank you you
haven't even got it on the i've
managed to do it and you've picked it up
marvellous um well
um obviously if um you know we can have
two members then i would i was going to
propose
um councillors keys and hull um
to be on that group chairman
okay if councillor how are you happy for
that
yes i'm happy to do it thank you
um if there's no one else then yes that
that will be great the other
you chairman thank you the other two
committees
are the um or the parish clerks foreman
forum which is myself the chair of
pg a um and
the other one is the river crouch
coastal community team which i
notice is the chairman and vice chairman
of performance governance and strategy
and resources
so if everybody is happy with that are
you happy to take those recommendations
on consent
really great thank you good
item
14 on the agenda is any other items of
business that the chairman of the
committee decides are urgent
there are none so therefore i will close
this
meeting at 13
15 31 so i will thank all the officers
for all the hard work you have put into
making these reports
and i thank all the councils for
attending this
and thank you berna for taking the
minutes
thank you chairman thank you